right so in this video we what we will
be doing is we'll be going over acids
and bases particularly acids but their
importance in talking about biochemistry
okay so we're going to be going over
acids and bases okay and we're going to
talk about them specifically as far as
how they apply to biochemistry so when
we talk about two my biochemistry acids
and bases we particularly deform
consider the bronsted definitions so the
bronsted definition for an acid is a
proton donor and a base the
bronsted-lowry definition is a proton
acceptor okay so it's very important to
keep these two definitions these two
simple definitions in mind what we're
talking about acids and bases so when we
think about the acids or bases we
usually think about the classical
reaction which is this okay so the
classical reaction I'm talking about I
don't know if it's really called that
but it's kind of how I think about it so
I think about an acid as being something
carrying a proton right so this here
will be the acid and if we put this in
water water will be acting as the base
and this is what's gonna happen
so before okay now before I go on I want
to label these two really quickly so
like I said this H a here will be the
acid and this water here's where we to
act as a base so given that we know that
this acid will be donating a proton this
H here at the positive charge to the
base here which was accepted okay so
then what we get then
is if water is going to accept the
proton it becomes h3o plus and if the
acid is going to give up the proton it's
ends up just being a minus and a a I'm
pretty certain stands for an ion right
because it carries that negative charge
so then what we have these two species
are are now considered they have two
names so now this here is carrying a
proton right so now it's actually in an
acid form so it's called a conjugate
acid now the reason it's called the
conjugate acid is because obviously
because it's an acid right because it's
carrying that proton but this base was
protonated it gained that proton to
become this conjugate acid and this here
this anion is simply then the conjugate
base alright and this makes sense
because now this thing can go go and
donate a proton act as an acid and this
anion here can accept a proton and
become this acid okay
another way to depict this right you
don't you can omit the water and simply
write it like this you can write it as H
a right just an acid dissociating into
H+ and an anion okay now I want to
connect these really quickly just so I
can be absolutely clear this acid right
becomes this conjugate base here right
and this base here becomes this acid
okay that's how they're connected I'm
here we obviously omit the base we just
consider the acid as being dissociate as
associating in the water so the water is
actually still here so you just kind of
write that there okay anyway what we can
often do or what we can do is write out
what's called the KA expression and the
KA expression is the equilibrium
constant expression but specifically for
assets so if we write the if you recall
just equilibrium
and writing them back from general
chemistry you would write them as the K
expression is equal to the product the
concentration of the products over the
concentration of the reactants so in
this case we're calling it the KA
because it's an ass dissociation
equation so we're gonna have the
concentration of the products right
which are the h plus and the a- over the
concentration of the reactants right
which is that acid that's that's
protonated still okay now from this here
from this KA expression we're going to
derive what is called the henderson
hasselbalch equation which will be very
very useful when it comes to thinking
about whether or not certain functional
group is protonated or deprotonated or
in the acid form of the base form all
this might not make sense just yet but
it will make sense in future videos
trust me this is just an overview as far
as how to find the henderson hasselbalch
it or how to derive the anderson ASSA
Bloch equation so now once we have this
what do we do okay so what we're gonna
do what I wanted to do is now that I
have this I'm going to rewrite it over
here that's really ugly anyway so I'm
going to rewrite it and in a slightly
different way write it like this oops
goodness
okay sorry about that okay so we're
gonna have ka equals the H+
concentration times the N ion
concentration over the undissociated
acid concentration now what we're going
to do is take the log of both sides okay
so we're going to take the log of this
and the log of this entire thing here
now notice here this is the log of a
product right so if you guys recall back
in math the log of a product log of XY
for instance will be equal to the log of
X plus the log of Y okay so what we get
here is we get the log of the KA is
equal to the log of the H+ concentration
plus the log of a minus over H a okay
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take this log of ka and move it over to
this side and see this log of h plus
we're already the other side you guys
see why in just a moment so if I do that
they both simply just become negatives
right so I get negative log of h plus
concentration equals the negative log of
UK a constant potion okay a constructs
just the K plus the log of a minus over
H a okay so now if you recall back to
general chemistry this negative log of h
plus is defined as pH and this negative
log of ka is defined as the pKa so if we
rewrite this this equation now what we
get is we get the we get the pH is equal
to the pKa plus the log
of the conjugate base over the
undissociated acid now this thing here
this equation here is now the henderson
hasselbalch equation person now this
equation is very very useful in
biochemistry it can tell us basically
whether like I said earlier if a
particular group is protonated or not
essentially if we if we know there are 3
there are 3 variables here in this
equation there's the pH the pKa and this
ratio here between the conjugate base
and the acid so if we know for instance
the pH and the pKa then we can determine
and solve for this ratio here basically
and basically what I wanted to mention
is that if you have two of these
variables you can solve for the other so
if you knew the pKa and this acid or
base acid ratio then you could determine
what the pH is now that may not make all
the sense in the world just yet but if
you watch future videos it'll make sense
I promise one more thing I wanted to
know before I go on before I end the
video we're just a few things so what I
wanted to to mention and have you guys
recall was that strong acids right based
on that definition from earlier if an
acid is a strong acid
first of all acids our proton donors if
something is a strong acid that means
it's going to be very good at donating
its proton okay so it's a very good
proton donor right so if something has a
very good proton donor then that means
it's going to exist in its conjugate
base form now that might not make sense
that adhering it the first time but
think about that for a moment
if this acid is very very good at
getting rid of its proton then this it
won't be existing in this acid form
it'll be existing
the conjugate base form because it will
have donated its proton to another
species so the Lofton people what
they'll say is that a strong acid will
ionize completely and what that simply
means is that if you you know if you
have an acid all of it will be turned
into that proton and the anion so so
that's what a strong acid is find that
there are six strong acids if you
remember that I'm HCl HBR
H I nitric acid sulfuric acid and
perchloric acid so all of those acids
are very very good proton donors and
they will exist most commonly in their
conjugate base form so for instance an
example HCl it will exist mostly as H+
and Cl minus right so that's what strong
acids are and what I wanted to mention
in addition to that is is that strong
acids have high ka values and they have
low PKA values let's think about this
for a second a high ka value something
has a high ka value we should look at
this we should consider this means a
high ka value that means it's going to
have this number on top this or this
this value so this entire value will be
a large number does that make sense well
the sign extends according to this
definition if something is a very good
proton donor that's what it means it's
going to exist in its conjugate base
water so they're going to be a lot of
conjugate base in addition it has to
give it give up its proton so it makes
sense here then that if there's a bunch
of this and a bunch of this around right
that that that's what a strong acid
would be like right and it'd be very
little undissociated acid around so this
number this peak this treatment is ka
num number will be a very very large
number and if you take the negative log
of that it would be a very small number
okay so it's important to keep these two
ideas in mind when thinking about strong
acids I don't go into strong bases very
much although there
definition is simply that they're very
good proton acceptors but the reason why
I didn't really want to mention that
because oftentimes in biochemistry we
kind of stick to talking about the KA
expression and the pKa is a lot and
relating that to the pH so I hope that
was helpful when kind of clearing things
up as far as acids and bases and I hope
that was a good introduction to what
we'll be talking about in biochemistry